what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch from new rock stars
today moon night episode 3 easter eggs
and breakdown oh my god greg where what
do you keep getting these moon knight
shirts from epic hero shop you know they
told me that like that's the only way
you can get away with reacting to our
videos is if you buy a shirt so all
these other reactors were not wearing
epic hero shop
look out for them copyright strikes
they're coming i don't lie just to try
to benefit myself
what do i look like
amber heard oh
shots fired at ezra miller
take that yeah jk rowling we're
controversial
okay
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a breakdown of moon 9
episode 3 that made my mind meltmate
like oh my days oh my moon gods what is
going on like guys are you seeing what
i'm seeing right now do you know beauty
possible ramifications that the events
of this episode could mean for the
future of the mcu guys the entire planet
went back in time 2 000 years i'm sorry
my voice is like this this is a big deal
i'm gonna stop right now we're always
worried about what the ramifications for
the future the mcu will be when stuff
like this happens and nine times out of
ten
nothing we don't hear anything about
consequences
i love how right off the bat the episode
starts us off with a cut from black that
starts off blurry but gets more clear
revealing layla having her pictures
taken for fake illegal ids like what a
great cinematography choice by series
director mohamed diab and series
director of photography gregory
middleton because it feels like the
audience is waking up from that
blackness to an unfocused blurriness
like eyes first waking up and then
revealing layla in focus right
eventually reflecting the overall theme
of mark spector and stephen grant
constantly waking up from blackout
believe it disoriented themselves and
the fact that we begin outside of mark
or steven's point of view which is rare
for the series tells us that there is
some legitimacy to his experience or
that layla might also be experiencing
the delusion and then we get a look at
leila's fake passport to the arab
republic of egypt with the information
being edited on a computer screen by a
close family forger friend of leyla's
stating that leila's full name is
actually laila abdullah el faoli and
that she was actually an egyptian born
in cairo on october 28 1994 on a day
when the moon was actually in its waning
crescent phase i might add which is
quite interesting considering layla's
personal choice of murder jewelry in the
form of a shoulder stabbing crescent
shaper no i love that attention detail
and add a possible family connection
with the moon god concho himself as that
necklace could be a family heirloom of
sorts that is a good point because they
keep reminding us that konchu really
wants layla but they haven't specified
why necessarily but i think this latest
episode probably gave the most clues and
then you add that on top of it stands a
reason that's something to do with her
lineage is why she would be the perfect
vessel
for consu himself or
he's a perf
i heard she just appreciates moon shaped
jewelry she is hot she is hot that she
likes moons too i better get inside that
mind i mean her middle name abdallah
does mean flower of the god after all so
maybe that's a clue there and then we
learned that this fake passport has an
issue date of may 29 2019 which heavily
implies that layla herself was not
snatched by thanos in infinity war which
is also the same case for mark specter
as we see from an earlier episode's
passport as well though we can't 100
take this as a reliable source since
this is a fake id after all being faked
again by a close lied
who is no stranger to comic book tv
shows as she recently appeared on the tv
show gotham as lydia bishiri the bar
owner of lydia's bar and while layla is
talking to this forging family friend
she reveals to her that her and mark
spector once had a place together not 20
minutes away from steven's current
apartment where nemo the second is
almost assuredly floating at the top of
that tank because he has not gotten food
for a very long time
very
to hide out in the first place as steven
grant probably to remind him of the love
that he's been forced to leave behind as
this new fist of conscience and layla
also reveals that it's been 10 years
since her last visit to her homeland of
cairo which is curious to me considering
that she does note later on in the
episode that her name isn't the most
popular around those parts you should be
here why because my name pisses off a
few people in cairo so i'm very curious
to learn what exactly happened within
her family's history to cause all the
locals to be giving a family of
archaeologists the side eye i mean she
had to be gone for 10 years for a reason
after all but it might just have to do
with layla's current profession as a
type of ancient artifact robin hood
figure that steals from the
anti-collecting underground to return
those various valuable pieces of history
back to their respective cultures as she
believes all of these artifacts to be
stolen a completely not wrong belief
also shared by a former anti-clinton
exactly
during his totally normal field trip to
a museum that wasn't at all a robbery
yeah that's the thing where my mind was
actually going was that when you have
like archaeological or paleontologists
exploring in certain areas locals can
get like a little bit upset after doing
such a thing stands for reason that's
probably what it is and i feel like the
character that they are switching her
for based off of what we saw in episode
three and then the comics was a
character named marlene and that's what
i was referencing when we were doing our
reaction maybe slapped together with
some other character that i'm not
familiar with but it's a riff off of
that specific one who is the daughter of
a
archaeologist
archaeologist
archaeologicalologist
belongs in a mu museum because we know
that she deals with black market
antiques this might just mean that she
knows the power broker from falcon in
the ware soldier who we already know
loves antiques and all like paintings
and all that stuff and match report
sharing carter to pop up at some point
this season especially since the pirate
country madrapore is literally name
dropped a little bit later
good morning i'm sure you two will have
a lot to talk that's a solid point
ladies reminisce about leila's late
father who was an archaeologist that
apparently brought his daughter along on
all of his digs possibly alluding to the
dead archaeologists hinted at in the
last episode this of course sounding
extremely similar to the circumstances
of comic mark spectre's love interest
marlene allaron whose father was [ __ ]
the god i said a crazy mercenary named
bushman during marxism
but he also learned from his foreign
lady that layla's father liked to call
layla his little scarab possibly linking
layla and her family to the series
mcguffin the golden scarab leading to
the greatest treasure of all robin
williams in the cave of wonders
just kidding that's another disney owned
franchise i mean the tomb of vomit like
maybe layla was always meant to be
amit's true avatar who knows and then
you get the marvel studios logo coming
in maybe she just gets under your skin
like the 1999.
called enter which is actually a bop and
a dope way to hint at the faithful
portrayal of a modern-day cairo that
moon knight director mohammad diya was
extremely keen on delivering even going
as far as calling egypt's depiction in
hollywood media like you know wonder
woman 1984 disgraceful this word is not
mine i haven't even seen wonder woman
1984 so i can't even hate on that movie
and you know what after watching how
beautifully and differently this episode
of moon knight captures the vibrant
excitement of a 21st century cairo in a
way that i've never seen before
personally this director might just know
what he's talking about because cairo
looks dope as hell in the show that's
true there is something to be said about
that because nine times out of ten
whenever we go to like egypt and movies
or something like that it's always just
so off-putting the way they like flesh
it out like i'm sure like their pyramids
are good to look at and everything but
the actual like city and civilization
the way that it's usually captured is
this looks unpleasant
yeah they usually just plop you in a
dingy bazaar and call that all of egypt
yeah but they they really instilled a
lot of life in there a lot of credit has
to be given to that because this is the
first time where i went what about
traveling there one day well yes
imagine what could happen when somebody
who knows this place intimately captures
it for you on february but anyways when
we first meet arthur harrow following
the golden compass to his favorite
crocodile queen i could not help but get
the image golden compass matthew vaughn
his own people through the deserts of
egypt in the judaic scriptures with the
figure of moses often being drawn as a
prominent figure in red much like arthur
harrell seems to be the only person
wearing red amongst this group in the
desert feel like there's a very
intentional design yeah good call man
this episode he's doing exactly what
leila thought he was doing and trying
not to get himself killed running around
cairo he's probably going to get himself
killed running around cairo
and when mark gets into a fight with
some dramatic knife fighting guys with
the lead one even tossing a knife up to
the camera like some sort of cool guy
giving us a slow-mo zooming of that
knife throw that reminds me of the wasp
dodging knives in the kitchen in ant-man
and the wasp wait a minute we saw at
this one point though when he was
running through the clothesline that he
lost his hat
oh and then later on he's wearing
that hat
did he
run back to get that hat or did he steal
another hat and i'm not remembering that
scene khan shooters has his own hats
some in the hat some of the some of the
hats
we're out in daylight caught you please
stop with the hat jake but then we get
some really dope knife combat back in
the mcu since the amazingness that was
that winter soldier knife fight from
many moons ago with that alpha thug
taking the lead being the actor jaleel
nasiri who is showing us some of that
amazing knife skill that made liam
neeson sweat during that final battle in
the first taken movie
cool
and then he's the knife guy he's been
pulling a punch before choosing to slap
this young thug over here which sort of
calls back to his other personality's
conversation with arthur harrow's last
episode when he brings up his blatant
objection to hurting children what about
a child would she kill a child for
something they might do in 30 years i
kind of draw a line there at child
murder so even though these two are
separate personalities it seems like
they have very similar values take him
to the ledge i thought he just would
have punched after mark blacks out in
the middle of that roof fight we get our
first look at waking up from a
personality switch from mark's
perspective as steve tries to book it
out of egypt in a cab which you know i
don't i don't believe him he's like all
right i'm in another country again time
to go home
i hope i'm just nonchalant about like i
did it again
and i thought it was absolutely
hilarious when we get the cab driver a
little later yelling where's my money to
moon knight as it felt like it could
have been like a slight nod to the
famous
yelling i know you're here dracula you
big bird where's my goddamn mummy well i
think one thing that a lot of people
were wondering i know it was robin our
video too is how you know he wakes up in
a cab which could be a reference to jake
lockley the third personality that is a
cab driver and he even does say to him
the cab driver does say
something about the language that he's
all of a sudden started speaking english
to some effect like that something was
pointed out and so it seemed like it was
probably another hint that that could
have been jake lockley in there i
remember setting him up to be some type
of egyptian personality they changed
steven grant a lot so i wouldn't be
surprised if they also decided to
drastically change jake locklear and
then one of the biggest what moments of
the show happens when mark actually
catches up with those culti roof thugs
on the street and gets bumped on the
head twice once by a thug with a blunt
object and once again after his head
lands hard on the ground which seems to
cause him to wake up from the actions of
an entity that is neither mark or
stephen a version of mark who seemingly
didn't care about getting the
information mark needed out of these
people you know what a lot of people do
not point out a lot of the way they
visually illustrate this whole like hop
in between time and segments and
blacking out and committing crimes and
actions is a lot like the movie
limitless
oh
have you seen limitless no
tell me about it
well that happens to limitless a lot
just kill them literally everyone but
this young boy gets gutted by this
mysterious new personality a personality
that i hope and believe to be that of
jake blockley the street smart new york
cab driver who has up until this point
been largely absent in the series and
with moon knight's mirror cinematography
seemingly hinting at three personalities
hidden inside this one marked body this
actually made up ending being the case
as that would be extremely comic book
accurate and of course before this young
boy cuts his red scarf to meet the base
amit in the sky he says
much like the agents of mcu's first main
cults hydra would yell hail hydra before
they committed suicide
and then went directly to hell because
they were nazis but hey speaking of this
boy scarf who really interested in the
judge that i've been noticing with the
moonlight series is that a lot of mark
and steven's enemies seem to be adorned
in this particular shade of red you know
this boy's scarf and hair the cops that
stopped by steven's house the goons that
shot ah
good catch arthur harrow himself hell
even midnight man was wearing red
particularly a shade of red similar to
that of the scarlet witch and her chaos
magic which arthur has hinted could be
playing a factor between both him
there's co-austin
this shade could be indicative of some
chaos magic influence in the series but
anyways konchu finally gives us some
details about how moonite's healing
armor is able to give him a healing
factor that rivals wolverine with both
mark and steve proving this by taking
several polls
passing away during their battle at
moguards a battle that reminded me so
much of theater quill and avengers
infinity war when steve grant calls
timeout and tells everyone to chill the
f out we're all worked up let's all just
like chill the f out everybody stay
where you are chill the f out but
anyways
the one thing in the universe that he
fears the wrath of the council of gods
which kanchu later has to face through
this avatar inside the great pyramid of
giza one of the seven wonders of the
world which secretly doubles as a
council room for the pantheon of
egyptian gods as nine seats for each god
avatar can be seen though only five of
the nine isis tefnut osiris hathor and
horus show up for conscious trial after
he literally moved the moon to make an
eclipse to make this meeting even
possible and yaziel avatar to the
goddess of music and love hathor played
by native american actress diana
bermudez also hints at a hidden
potentially romantic past between hathor
and kanchu when she says nice it was not
so long ago conscious enjoyed hathor's
melodies as far as i know the only
melody conscious enjoys is the sound of
pain which does make sense considering
that konchu and hathor have had a
romantic past in egyptian mythology
source material or is also in addition
to music and love the goddess of the sky
these two were a match made in heaven
literally made in the heavens
the moon without the sky but yeah guys i
need you but i do not trust hathor at
all like zero percent not our avatar
however seems nice especially when this
flash of white colored light seems to
appear over harrow's head right before
half lure leaves the mind of yet see
check that out slow it down i definitely
feel like the goddess hathor and hero
are in cahoots like you can't trust
nobody with an h in the front of their
name in this show okay i have this
feeling that because i think you're
right about that
she could actually be the true villain
of this series trying to create a heaven
on earth so her and her banished former
lover konshu could live together on and
look at the stars together forever
because like i said hathor is the
goddess of the sky and the sky and the
moon are always meant to be together no
matter what which could be why konchu
says that he remembers every night
because he is remembering his love for
the sky or
wow that's a pretty wild theory and it
actually lines up quite a bit i gotta
give credit to mt on that theory man
yeah that would be a really cool way to
blend both things you could extrapolate
from the show itself but then also
incorporate mythology and everything i
mean i felt like that was the last we'd
seen of her yeah i know so what a great
way to bring that back around and have
it be a unpredictable twist that only mt
was able to predict and then also kind
of humanize conch you a little bit more
as well really add more layers and
nuance to the characters if your theory
were to actually come true but anyways
when the leader of the group horus says
you've been banished once for nearly
exposing us honshu and you know we
despise your garishness
your showy masks and weapons we learned
that not only do these gods really have
no love for consu but they're also not
wants to have actively violent
flamboyant avatars with boon-themed
weapons running around the earth very
much implying that for now moon knight
is the only avatar of his kind though i
do suspect that arthur herrera will end
up becoming the shadow knight who is in
the comics and you know basically just
an evil wound i'm not sure if i want to
see that happen
but it's the marvel classic
howard guy but evil what else are you
gonna do i don't know about that man it
would be nice to see them go with a
stronger more interesting choice keep
them still like a little bit of a lex
luthor-ish
kind of thing where his intelligence
because this guy's already able to hop
around in the most unusually relaxed
state all the time kind of keep him with
that level of cool confidence if he just
becomes you know another killmonger iron
monger and we also learned that these
gods have all abandoned mankind because
mankind has abandoned worship of them
with konchu claiming that all of these
gods are living in opulence in a place
called the overvoid better known in the
marvel comics as the celestial
helioptics a pocket dimension outside
the main marvel that's so beautiful
in paradise something that both konchu
and four force poor the god butcher
share a problem with because gore does
not like that the gods do not help
mankind out at all but anyways when mark
and layla are on that purpose it might
be why we haven't got that trailer here
and to mark struggle with his mental
illness with him telling layla that he's
been struggling with it for a very long
time until something happened recently
that caused him to lose the control that
he's mastered over it over the years
with that something very likely being
his first meeting with konchu he
probably messed with his brain chemistry
and we finally get a look at gaspard
yuliel's anton mogart also known as
marvel's midnight man a villain in moon
knight's rogues gallery who love to
steal valuable things not for the money
but simply for the sake of having them
kind of like the collector from
guardians of the galaxy one and mogar
earns the title of midnight man in the
comics simply because of his preference
to strike at the dead of night at
midnight for all of his crimes which is
why we see country saying tick-tock over
a clock that just struck midnight at the
very end of this incredible experience
and of course the late guest bard would
have a tribute from marvel at the very
end of this episode rest in peace
and speaking of tick-tock on the clock
guys i'm not sure if you missed this but
it kind of seems like konshu in an
effort to you know return the stars to
the position that they were 2 000 years
in the past when senpu first marked the
tomb of ahmet thought that the only way
to do that was to change the sky itself
by turning back time which could be the
reason for the beautiful light show at
the episode's end it's literally the
stars in the sky going back in time and
how exactly can concha do this by
manipulating gravity something that the
moon is heavily associated with and
possibly why konchu was able to
effortlessly cause an eclipse earlier on
in the episode by moving the moon and
guys if this is the case and the earth
has been sent 2 000 years into the
universe's past do you guys know what
this means this means that the infinity
stones are back asgard is back xandar is
back ella's back eagle the living planet
is back the entire universe is just 2000
years younger like in my opinion this is
potentially one of the biggest things to
happen to the mcu since the snap mostly
because we see conscious turned to stone
before he can put this guy back where he
found it like man oh man can i not wait
to see how this could potentially change
the entire mcu game for phase four
because this is freaking nuts man
freaking nuts i think that is so
cool and so
true i don't think they're going to do
anything
i really don't i don't know if they'll
even bother to put the sky back
like i finished that might be the last
or just nervous come on
and freaking loki was it was more
monumental and instrumental i'm sure
will have an effect probably in
multiverse and madness and such back to
what i said really there's always
something that's like this could change
everything and it just doesn't there
should be a list of all those events
because you know that they'll come back
to them 10 years down the line and make
them significant when they need new
story ideas but i would love to be wrong
and finally we end the episode with the
revelation that not only did arthur
harrow truly enjoy herding in the name
of kanchu but that kanchu was the very
reason why he chose this weird path of
healing because kanju was the one who
gave him a taste for blood and
destruction and he even goes as far as
to thank the imprisoned country for his
victory to come and man you know ethan
hawk can act when you forget that he's
straight up sassing at a statue of a
bird for like 60 seconds
but anyways that is it for this
breakdown of moon knight episode three
what did you guys think of this episode
like do you guys think that i'm crazy
and the earth didn't actually go back in
time 2000 years because it looks like
that's what happened let us know what
you thought in the comment section below
my nerd babies because i want to hear it
i want to hear it but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] and really fun
theories more importantly you can follow
new rockstars wherever we are on social
media thank you guys so much for
watching this video i love you guys so
much and i appreciate you guys always
spending time with me seriously i love
you see you guys next time what seemed
really sincere and sweet
i love you too love you too look through
it love you uptake yeah i mean i feel
like that he just kind of changed the
placement of the stars and such and
that's why everyone was looking up you
didn't see like the lands going back or
people vanishing back in time yeah time
traveled it's it's it's it opens up a
whole other set of questions because
you're like okay so earth is still in
the present but we're just in the past
of the universe and will that really
matter or is this just another brand
show entirely yeah yeah yeah yeah i
don't i don't think so don't think
about it yeah when you apply the science
to stuff
stop it don't
because simply moving the moon to create
that eclipse is going to ruin a bunch of
stuff
that didn't happen so all right guys
well what do you think leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
last but not least
adelia chamberlain i've gotten to know
you quite a bit
and i would suspect there's probably a
little bit of a mark specter inside of
you waiting to come out currently you
kind of write the stephen grant thing a
little bit uncomfortable in social
circumstances you're very nice but i can
feel that there's a rage in you that is
just waiting to come out unload on
people
specifically the alt-right if we're
being completely honest with ourselves
but if that's what it takes you might as
well go for it i say you only live once
might as well see how far you can go
knowing how real life works you'll get
arrested on the spot and not go very far
with it but it would be very
entertaining stuff and i support you all
the way because i love you so get out
there
halfway
towards succeeding and
breaking a guy's widow
i don't know where you guys were going
when i was some of my petty [ __ ]
yeah yeah slasher nazi's tire today yeah
not not like actually hurting people
yeah it's messed up you know yeah that's
too far
you guys are sick
what are you ezra miller
shots fired at ti
[Music]